hello everyone and welcome back to the
Lind or Abby rapid challenge we are in
the final game of the match so this is
the third match and this is the
Armageddon game so after four games the
the result is a tie and now we have to
settle everything Magnus with the white
pieces Hikaru was the one who chose
black as he did mention once that he
prefers black as he spends less time
than the other player so he doesn't mind
having already less time from the start
in the Armageddon and if you don't know
if you don't follow them on Twitter yeah
there's been a sort of also a Twitter
rivalry going on after winning on day
one and Magnus tweeted moan cos which if
you don't know what it is if you're like
me and you don't know what it is yeah I
will explain it because after
retaliating on day two Nakamura also
tweeted mangas which means well it's
it's basically an emote on twitch based
on Pepe the Frog and the monk as means
that it's sort of a very tense situation
that you know it's like a suspenseful
situation so that's what both of them
meant by that first carlson tweeted it
at he called in Hikaru at Magnus
obviously and now we are about to see
how it all unwinds so without further
ado let's check it out so Magnus with
the white pieces opens with d4 he was
very happy with how he won in it with
how he retaliated in the third match
with the Queens gambit declined and he
of course doesn't mind repeating that
and we will have a repetition of the
game is basically again from the
previous video c4 we have e 6 Knight of
3 and B 5 the Queens gambit declined is
on the board and now Knight to c3 with
Bishop to e7 everything the same as in
the previous game and Bishop to f4 we
have castles and III now yeah we have
Knight B to d7 and now Bishop to e2
like we mentioned in the previous video
you wait for this Bishop to be developed
before you capture on c4 and now Magnus
it doesn't recapture but rather just
castles King side and in that game he
car went Knights to b6 he defended his
c4 pawn and it really didn't turn out
all that great for him so here he goes
for a6 instead and next he's gonna go b5
if Magnus
which of course Magnus doesn't he pushes
a for keeps an eye on the b v square and
now Knight to d5 again putting pressure
on the bishop here and there is one game
where Bishop captures and c4 was played
it was played at between adding glitter
and level narayana in the london chest
classic in 2019 editing leader and one
with the capturing and c4 but here at
magnus retreats with bishop the g3 and
now again there is a one game in the
database where well i think there's more
than one but one notable again between
david navara and vastly when shook where
b6 was played by chalky but here we have
a c5 and it is now a new move so already
as of move 10 we have a completely new
game and now magnus has to decide what
to do now he captures on c4 he carl
traits on d4 we have chakras captures in
now Knight 7 to b6 just shifting the
night over there attacking the bishop so
Bester back to be three and now not
allowing a5 to dislodge the night from
b6 Hikaru pushes a5 himself
we have Knight to e5 and excellent
square for the knight so our cross and
goes for it and Bishop to d7 now
preparing to shift the bishop board to
c6 to grab hold of this very strong
diagonal and now Knight to e4 by Magnus
now the two knights are both on
excellent excellent outposts and Bishop
the c6 just grabbing hold of this very
nice diagonal and the magnet decides the
trade now so Knight captures B captures
and rook to c1 so it's equal material
magnus still with the bishop repair and
he carved with the isolated C pawn
Magnus would be isolated deep on so what
happens now we have night the b4 by
Hikaru the knight from before will be
guarding the c6 pawn nicely and now you
make room for this night to come to d5
so the Knights are supporting each other
as they make their way down the board we
have Queen to e2
developing and preparing to bring the
other rook into the game and it's not
even a pawn sacrifice and see if you
capture this rook to d1 traps the Queen
all of these squares are taken so the
Queen has no squares also the b2 is
guarded by the Queen so instead we have
night six to d5 as planned and now rook
F to d1 so Magnus puts putting his
pieces on optimal square
rook to e8 by Hikaru now preparing to
shift the bishop over to f8 as Magnus is
preparing some Bishop e5 action followed
by shifting the Queen to g3 which will
put pressure on g7 so it does make sense
to develop the rook but also to shift
the bishop over to f8 Queen to f3 and
the now comes rook to e7 getting the
rook away from this diagonal but also
helping out with the support of the
seventh rank also in the future you will
be able to double up rooks and the
e-file if you want to push ePHI for
example so Bishop to e5 and now Bishop
to f8 already defending g7 will Queen to
g3 by Magnus now just putting a lot of
pressure on g7 if the bishop ever moves
it will be checkmate and now he Kerry
decides that it's definitely time to
kick away the bishop from a five so he
pushes f6 we have Bishop to d6 by Magnus
Bishop captures and now Knight
characters the Queen can also capture
but Magnus really needs a win in this
game otherwise he loses the match and he
does not go into the final finals of the
island or a saboteur phase dubov so
Knight captures and b6 attacks the
rookin e8 and rook back to f8 now we
have Knight back to e4 by Magnus and now
Queen to b8 offering the Queen trade
which Magnus declines so just Queen back
to f3 and now rook back to EA now again
he car wants to double up on the e-file
and push he five we have g3 by Magnus
not allowing Queen to f4 iso Hikaru
cannot offer a queen trade and now King
to a trade not much safer Square for the
King getting the King away from this
diagonal as like we mentioned you want
to push 'if I've with Knight the c5 by
Magnus and of course now rook 8e 7
doubling up and preparing a 5 we have
Bishop to c4 and Magnus now can really
make that Queen side solid by playing b3
everything will be nicely defended but
he car goes c5 and okay we have captures
here he caricaturists with the Queen now
with the very nice Rock row queen
battery and now rook the d2 guarding the
b2 pawn so Queen to g5 now putting
pressure on both of the
rooks and now Magnus defense with Knight
to b3 nicely defending both rooks and
now Knight back to b6 putting pressure
on the bishop and first h4 now attacking
he carves Queen Hikaru goes back Queen
to e5 and now rooked Ito just attacking
that Queen and I remember yesterday when
we when we were at the party we checked
out the position a little bit and it was
at this point that I saw the position
and I was like okay Queenie a rookie -
it looks very nice you know anything can
still happen here and it doesn't seem
like white is having much much problems
here but you know we'll see what happens
next we have Queen to c7 by Hikaru
Magnus trades a pair of rooks captures
captures and now grabs the a five point
Knight captures on a5 and here Magnus is
up upon and he created a past a pawn so
if he can move back the night start
pushing the pawn it's gonna be very good
for him
and now Hikaru can also choose to grab
EA for pawn but then you get Queen to b3
attacking the knight and after the
knight retreats now you grab this pawn
Knight captures captures and just
captures and we would have this position
where Magnus is up a pawn and it's a
fast beep on it's uh well it's it should
only be a matter of time before before
white can convert this so Hikaru instead
decides to keep as much material on the
board as possible for the moment he goes
Queen e5 again puts pressure on the b2
pawn and we have Knight back to b3 by
Magnus offering that point but it's it's
not really offering a pawn because well
before we actually show what happened
there is a disgusting engine line here
Magnus is in fact winning here but it's
such such a disgusting line so I'm just
gonna show it to you guys
it's Bishop to f7 now at the point is
now that the rook has to move you've
attacked the rook and you kind of don't
want to move it away from the back rank
to weaken your back back back rank so
rook f8 you attack the bishop but now
Knight captures and c6 attacks the Queen
end the night and now you either go for
Knight captures and c6 Queen captures
where you will be unable of course to
capture the bishop here and well a 5 is
just coming it's
really hard a tough position of course
if you capture this then the point is
you sacrifice the Queen for mate
captures captures with check and after
you give up the rook and the Queen it
will just gonna be checkmate so what you
can do after Knight captures on c6 is go
Queen captures and beat you for black
but it's still not good enough
rook to d1 again exploiting the
weaknesses of the back rank and now
let's say after knife captures on a4 now
you go Knights to d8 you defend the
bishop the rook defends the night and
now your idea is Queen III followed by
Queen to e7 and black will have to give
up the rook so Queen c3 offering your
Queen trade but now Queenie for again
with the same idea and now you don't you
can't really go all that far away with
the black Queen you need to keep an eye
on these nights so you could try
something like Queen to c2 forcing a
trade but it only favours white captures
captures and now push it back to be
three with a double attack tonight the
c3 going after the rook but now night f7
check King to g8 and now rook the d8
forcing a trade here and there is well
not much to be done here if you don't
want to face a double a double check
from the knight and the bishop default
by checkmate you have to capture and
then it's just captures with check King
has to move and Bishop captures and c2
so like I said a truly disgusting engine
line now but I felt it was it was okay
to show it so yeah
Bishop to f7 would have been winning
here Magnus goes back with Knights to b3
and now we have Knight captures on a4
not going for the B to pawn but first
for the a for pawn it's a much more
dangerous point and you will grab on b2
next and Magnus goes for Bishop to f7
now but now it's one move too late as
you no longer have a knight here to
combine it with Knight captures on c6 so
rook the faith by Hikaru and now rook
the c-4 by Magnus offering the bishop to
start gobbling up the Knights here we
have rook captures on f7 by Hikaru and
now here's the problem here yes
Magnus needs the went back one of the
Knights however you first need to block
the Queen which either rook or Quinta e4
first the Queen back and now play trick
on his back rank like Hikaru did in Game
two with Quinta
for offering a force attacking the Queen
and also with a double attack on the
night here and point is if you capture
the Queen then roku delivers mate in two
moves of course and after rook to f8
defending the Queen then you recapture
the night and then the game continues
however Magnus grabbed the knight
immediately and now this just wanders
the game completely so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the
winning move for for Hikaru while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations on finding a nice check
fouled by I win your rook and for those
of you who just wanna enjoy show its
Queen to e one check this is what Magnus
missed and this is what cost him the
game so it's check you're gonna lose the
rope Magnus played king h2 and Hikaru
just to gobble up the rooks or queen
capture son before and after
Magnus played Queen captures and c6 now
with the idea that he wants to deliver
mate using again back rank issues he
could just played rook to f8 and it was
in this position unmoved 42 that Magnus
Carlsen resigned the game and with it
the semi-final match and it is Hikaru
who advances to the final match at the
face Daniel dubov so you know we're
gonna see it's gonna be it's gonna be a
wild one but yeah it was a really really
intense match Magnus completely winning
in match 1 with three zero then he
caught retaliating and then we have this
just you know for games of intense
action and then going into Armageddon to
finally get a winner so this is like I
said
Magnus also had a whoa that's that's not
what I wanted to show Magnus also had
something to say on Twitter after after
this match he says I will be back and
also when you're the best and cocky
about it a lot of people love to see you
fail so enjoy it while you have the
chance you deserve it and Hikaru of
course just tweeted his his famous GG oh
yeah there we have it that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it and the cover
of this semi-final match hope you
enjoyed that as well and also I have a
confirmed guest for the second podcast
it is yes in fact Hikaru Nakamura some
of you have successfully guessed it in
the stream and in the other videos so if
you want to add some of your questions
for me to include in the podcast do use
the email in the description below to
send me some of the questions and I will
I will go through all of them but of
course I will not be able to include all
of them I will only include some spam
once again I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Matthew Bennet
Richard McElveen Nikola Coolidge Wesley
Carter and Stefan funk for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it and we also
have a new top contributor to the
channel however it is a mystery person
since for at least for now I do not know
who this mystery person is so until he
or she identifies him or herself we will
refer to this person as mystery but yeah
once again I do hope you enjoyed it and
have an excellent rest of your Sunday